with the u.s. reimposing tough sanctions
on Iran the aim is to [ __ ] Iran's oil
dependent economy and to stop its
nuclear ambitions the first round of
sanctions sent Iran's currency into
freefall
just last month inflation topped 30
percent this next wave of economic
penalties is scheduled to take effect
next week and has some residents looking
for a way out Elizabeth Palmer reports
from Tehran Reza
Idun uses his family car as his taxi he
like everyone else in this city is
worried about the US sanctions but
people are still waiting what's
happening for Sunday the government is
telling you not to worry the
government's made sure basic services
like trash collection are working and
it's kept gas prices low about 90 cents
a gallon but in general prices have
skyrocketed so cheese for butter for job
for meat for chicken every time now
Mohammed the butcher says his poorest
customers can't afford his meat you give
them a deal yes the White House may be
betting that hardship will provoke the
kind of anti-government uprisings that
erupted here in 2009 but right now there
seems little appetite for it a few shops
down Hussein tells us the harder the US
pushes the more people will resist
everybody hand-to-hand we head for a
richer area where we meet the Hosseini's
I discussed it with both the US and
Iran's government s I'm an accountant is
voting with his feet no I want to escape
from Iran yes we want to leave to France
but very few get to leave the majority
are trapped by politicians and policies
they fear but can't control for CBS this
morning Saturday
I'm Elizabeth Palmer in Tehran that's
who they say the sanctions hurt yeah I
know you feel bad for the ordinary you
feel you belt feel bad for the ordinary
people in Iran who suffered through all
this the politics of this